everyone's outraged all the time we're
all offended all the time we're looking
for people to attack all the time in
comes Donald Trump into this thing now
you're a Donald Trump supporter right
yeah endorse Donald Trump all right
endorse Donald Trump I believe you're
the first Trump supporter that I've had
on the show so congratulations on that I
shared my feelings at the beginning
about Trump but before I give you more
of my feelings so gimme why is this
working for Trump sure it's working like
them or not busy at work and nobody's
getting that okay so when you have a
reaction you're gonna have a
counter-reaction
here's a robe we live in you're a
liberal you're a reasonable guy okay
that's not most liberals that just not
sadly I'm with you on that that's just
reality we've now taken God who's dead
we don't religion we now have the
religion of political correctness the
Liberals have now turned it to religion
where you know I could say well you
believe these things well I think you're
wrong maybe if we talk about it I'll
just get through to you well now I don't
even look at how you live you make a bad
tweet you're evil you think something
about this you're a bad person I always
use an example of you know like a lot of
people have facebook drama by people who
knew them and this happened recently so
we know this guy great guy he's actually
liberal all these liberal friends that
he posted you know guys I just think
it's weird that Bruce Jenner now like as
a woman and it's Caitlyn I just think
it's really weird that she would want to
do that right and his friends were like
oh my god you're transphobic big I can't
believe you said this they were texting
back Channel I thought this was a good
person yeah you know but it's weird
right this is a guy who you've only
known to be a decent guy for all the
time he says something that probably a
lot of people are actually right
thinking privately like there's
something I want to say weird I know
trans people trans people are great
people I have obviously no issue with
them but somebody could say that and
that in and of itself doesn't make them
a fake well I'm weird you're weird why
do you want to be on TV right why do I
have a podcast why do i troll these are
bullied when I was yeah right that's the
whole thing it's this concept that if
you live a lifestyle that is deviant
deviant doesn't necessarily always mean
bad weird doesn't mean
moral judgment it just means Wow that's
out of the realm of my experience right
a lot of people saw what I did early on
before I caught on I was like no trust
me like I know what I'm doing but
they're like dude you're on Twitter
you're just a maniac what are people
gonna think I know just try but if
people said Mike I think that's weird
I think that's a waste of time maybe
you're mentally ill I would say I get it
you're wrong I get it right no I don't
think you're a bad person for making
that judgment so a lot of times we want
to now think everything is a character
attack when ultimately you're just
saying well this is [ __ ] weird yeah I
don't really understand it and the what
you do when somebody doesn't understand
something you say well actually I mean
it's gender binary well what about you
know brain but then you get into other
issues too where you say well I thought
gender is a social construct and there
is no male/female brain but if there's
no male brain and no female brain then
how can I be a male body with a female
brain right and it's hard to extrapolate
all that on Twitter so instead people
are just like everybody yeah so the
interesting thing and then we'll get
back to trump with the with the trans
situation is that you know Caitlyn
Jenner now people are turning the left
is turning on her now because she said
that she's supporting Ted Cruz and I
watched I've never watched any of that
show but I did watch the little
five-minute part where she was sort of
defending why she's a Republican and you
know they're debating and the people you
know she's arguing with these housewives
or whatever these people are that have
no idea what they're talking about but
I've seen now people on the left turning
on her because she has a different
political view so two months ago she was
a hero to them right but now you think
differently politically so now you're
evil and that there's a danger there
yeah and I'll confess that I did watch
the show for research we'll call her
researcherid ax and Kaitlyn's position
was hey we're seven trillion in debt I
like yeah we should be able to use the
same restrooms
but come on like if the country Falls
everybody's gone you know so it isn't
even that the the views are wrong the
the views are just hey I'm focused on
bigger issues you know what happens to a
country if our economy collapses well
you're gonna have a lot bigger worries
then can you use a unisex bathroom
and but people you know they don't want
to see it so what happens now is you get
fixated on this marginal issue there's
this issue that only affects a real
small group of people and then you're
not allowed to focus on any other issues
or else you're evil
so yeah Katelyn would say well I support
Ted Cruz Ted Cruz is wrong about this
but hey we got really bigger issues and
that makes you a bad person right so for
the person that loves identity politics
this is like a real disconnect for them
right because they're like wait a minute
wait a minute you're trans so the thing
that you're supposed to care about most
is trans and here you have someone
saying well actually I care more about
the economy or security or whatever it
is and identity politics as I say
whittles us down to the point where if
you jump out of that little box people
start freaking out well here's what
everybody says now well as a white
straight sis man my experience is this
and well as a gay man my experience is
this and as a so we've taken the sort of
personal narrative and now we treat that
as like absolute reality there is no
issue other than your narrow slice of
experience and I think that is not I
don't think it's a fun way to live I
don't know why anybody want to live that
way it's a very narcissistic narrow view
on the world where what you want to do
is you want to think well there's a lot
of us we live in a pluralistic society
we got gays use Muslims blacks why it's
everybody else why don't we just figure
out how to get along because we're stuck
here together right and it's almost as
if all of those groups that you decided
have people within them who think
different things than the the bigger
group I don't know why that's such a
revolutionary thought but it seems to be
for a lot of people so wait we started
here with Trump I don't know how we got
over it there so okay so you take all of
this the social justice stuff and this
fear of saying what you think and all
that and that basically has led us to
Trump right right because Trump says
anything here's what people say why do
you like Trump cuz they'll say what's on
his mind and then people go well we say
what's on our mind when we tell you that
if you're a white man you hate everybody
you know you're making it's like yeah
and now you have the counterculture the
counterculture is what Trump is just
gonna say whatever is on his mind that's
counter to your narrative
and people like that people respect it
okay so I'm with you on that portion of
that piece of Trump I understand I'm I
hate political correctness the whole
show has been devoted to fighting it so
I understand that portion of it with
Trump but I think you just said
something interesting he'll say anything
and that's where I see the biggest
problem this guy people keep saying I
like him cuz I'll say anything but he's
also saying nothing at the same time
he's taken every position on everything
he you watch him in the debates he
stands now for things he used to be
against in many ways he's actually for
big government he's certainly not a
conservative all those things so is that
enough for you that's the part that I
just don't understand I get people are
on it on the emotional level but is that
in and of itself enough for you to vote
for somebody and be like let this guy be
the present okay I'll talk about people
first I'll talk about me
so people first everybody now knows
people lie okay Obama said in the
debates what eight years ago he was
asked if he supported gay marriage what
did he say yeah he didn't at the time
but he did we all know he did right we
all know we all know that Obama is in a
Muslim work we all know the Obama's
almost certainly agnostic he's certainly
not a Muslim he's almost certainly not a
Christian
we all knew in those debates that he
supported gay marriage but he couldn't
say it so now the ruse it's all over we
know they're all Liars they're all
scammers they're you know Obama's drone
struck people killed all kinds of
innocent people those wars keep going on
not a single Wall Street executive has
been indicted we know of Clinton I'm
tough on Wall Street we know not a
single person on Walsh we all know it's
[ __ ] right you all know it's a scam
so then what happens is if it's a scam
well then you just go with the best
showman and that's where we are now in
life we're gonna go with the best
showman that's people yeah now me
personally here's what I think Trump is
ultimately I and this could be my own
delusions but my views and Trump's are
very similar in that I'm a libertarian
with nationalist tendencies and what
that means it's you got to close the
border you got to make sure the right
people get in you can't let intolerant
people in and then large amounts of
social freedom within the country and
that's always been Trump's position
that's what I say well Trump is a
liberal on this course he is of course
he is if you live
in a society where people can kind of
get along and you let on the right
people then you can be socially liberal
right but do you think that the ends
justify the means I guess that that's
where I'm struggling with this situation
with him because I think that ultimately
and this is what I said at the top of
the show if he got in this is not
someone who would respect any law that
we have I don't think he would accept
that the executive branch that the
president is only one-third of the
government I think he would do whatever
he wants the example I gave is that you
know he's because he says anything he
said well I'm gonna when I'm president
Starbucks is gonna put merry Christmas
back on Christie on their coffee cups
that's a I know it's just that I got you
already you know like he's just saying
something crazy but I think that that
line of thinking is actually dangerous
isn't that what leads us to fascism when
you have a guy who comes in and says I'm
gonna do whatever I want I mean he's
telling us right now right right well
one of my specialties is actually con
law the three branches of government as
you mentioned who has the power to
declare war the sole power to declare
war Congress has the power one how many
wars have we had since World War two
probably 15 I don't know there how many
times X hundred I'm not sure how many
times is Congress declared war right
probably once or zero it hasn't happened
so we've had Vietnam we had Korea war
police action the Iraq the first one the
second Iraq war Afghanistan all right
Libya where Obama did so the executive
hasn't respected the legislative branch
for a long time and what's interesting
is that you can go back to before Obama
was elected and you can see liberals
saying we have an executive out of
control no7
right and then when Obama is elected the
Conservatives at the Cato Institute and
everybody like Obama's you know out of
control and but they all flip-flopped on
the issue mm-hmm so again is a
constitutional law Scott and I actually
am a constitutional law scholar yeah
it's all [ __ ] anyway
everybody everybody flip-flops on whoo
now Trump what can you really do right
you can't really do that much that's the
idea that the president is that powerful
he's going to be stopped he's going to
be stopped meaning what meaning
he's the really crazy stuff that people
think so you're not gonna round up 12
million people okay
you're not gonna create a federal police
force round up 12 million people start
kicking down doors it just it's not
gonna happen right and actually I don't
think that's really what he wants also
but he's saying it that's what I'm
saying here that this idea if you just
follow the ideas of what he's saying
this leads us to a bad place this is in
no defense of the establishment and I
get it I've given Obama [ __ ] on right
now we're bombing Syria right as we sit
here with no congressional authorization
so I get it
they all do this terrible stuff but I
think the through line of the Trump
thinking leads us to a guy four years
later who will be next that that's what
I fear here who will be next
I don't know right that's the thing is I
wish I could see the future but what
what if Trump actually does a great job
what if Trump actually takes on Wall
Street
what if Trump does solve the problem
with the border which is a problem our
social services are way overstressed now
we we can't anybody who's ever gone to
an ER in California talk to any ER
doctor it is it is a real mess so what
Trump is doing is he's setting a
cultural tone he's just saying okay we
got to figure this stuff out
which which is what we need to do okay
adults need to sit down at the table and
figure out okay we have illegal
immigrants what are we going to do
well the path that everybody has taken
is to say well yeah well maybe amnesty
maybe you know a path to citizenship
maybe this and maybe we'll clear for
border and maybe we'll do this maybe
we'll do that well it's time to actually
take an extreme position because what
happens right the Overtoun will you know
in negotiation how much do you want well
I want a billion dollars a year you're
out of your mind
but now you've anchored and and all this
stuff is cognitive bias persuasion the
anchoring bias right he's very open
about this yeah the way about how he
would negotiate he says I'm just taking
out something crazy right so there have
been all these studies that'll show if I
say well how many books do you think
we're in the Library of Alexandria 20
million or 1 million well depending on
off I say 20 if I say do you think there
was 20 million or more you'll say well I
think there was 30 million right but if
I say well do you think there was more
than 1 million or less than a million
books
there you're gonna be closer to a
million all because of the anchoring
cognitive bias so Trump is just creating
an anchor a really strong anchor point
and then from there you work your way
down and most people don't do that in
your real life most people you think
okay I want this job
well I better ask for a salary pretty
close to what I think they'll give me
ask for 50% more right right because
they're not going to say well that's
you've asked way too much well you're
just not gonna hire at all now you've
anchored a bigger number of them and now
you have a little bit of leverage and
then you work from there so
interestingly what Trump is doing in
certain way is really what people on the
Left do which is use feeling over fact
so I don't think you're defending him on
the fact-based stuff right this is all
emotion right you're defending him on
the emotional base up so that's that's
fascinating because I see people on the
right all the time say ben shapiro who
sat in that chair a couple weeks ago
saying you know all the people on the
left care about feeling more than fact
and what you're saying basically is that
Trump is using that very tactic and yet
he's running on the right so by all
humans so it's he really should be
running on the left and then they would
all love him because he's giving them
field if it was just the feel-good stuff
that they feel good about he's just
giving the people on the right something
that they feel good about I'm Ted Cruz
and I'm a constitutionalist who believes
in Liberty and the founding fathers
right okay is there a logical statement
there that you can analyze well he
believes in Liberty in that he doesn't
want people to marry who they well yeah
what is Liberty nice right Liberty is
you impose there was a great scene in
Magnolia I think that musical movie and
they go liberty fraternity well who
could oppose Liberty right we all do but
we have a different conception of
Liberty if I'm a fundamentalist
Christian well I want religious liberty
and I think religious liberty means I
shouldn't have to make a cake for gay
people okay if you're gay you think well
I'm an adult I should be able to enter
into contracts about my relationship
with other consenting adults so if I
just say well I support Liberty so then
what you do is you say well Ted Cruz
doesn't really support my conception of
Liberty but it's all [ __ ] I support
the Constitution right [ __ ] I said what
does that even mean right there's a lot
in the Constitution do you believe
abortion is in the Constitution or not
right
what does it protect so the idea that
politicians run on these logical points
and that people make their conclusions
based on logic is nonsense so yeah it is
funny when people fax over feelings well
I mean look at that you know not to get
too far ahead
look at that Michelle feels incident we
just happened you know oh I was grabbed
and almost thrown to the ground and this
man and then he watched a video yeah you
know it's still unclear to me so for
people that don't know what you're
talking about
basically Trump's campaign manager
apparently grabbed Michelle fields who
was a private reporter she showed a
little bit of a bruise on her arm in a
picture I watched a video a thousand
times it's still I just I don't know
I've been in those scrums a little bit
right I've been to those things yeah you
get people get pushed and pulled and
whatever so I don't really know what
happens so I'll leave it there but I but
you're a basic take on it is that she's
a [ __ ] artist great yeah it's all
it's all been overplayed she said on TV
well other than my dad dying this is the
worst thing that has ever happened to me
in my life everybody every come on
everybody uses feelings to manipulate
people if if you're about to be fired
from a job you can make two cases well
you know here's an excel sheet here's
how many of you as I bring you can bring
that into mmm-hmm and we go way back and
you promise me this that's all emotions
right we make most of our decisions
based on emotions we respect leaders
based on where monkeys were [ __ ]
monkeys right we want to think we're
better than that
and Donald Trump right now is the big
alpha monkey so okay so let's talk about
the Alpha part because I definitely
think that's part of it and he just is
up there exerting his alpha malice and
the rest of these guys simply aren't
alpha males so you can take a Marco
Rubio who even though I disagree with
him most things I think he's probably a
decent human being and he's in the right
line of work he's actually looked kind
of human the now that he's realized is
over he's looking kind of human as
opposed to the robot that we've been
seeing up there but you look at him
that's certainly not an alpha male you
look at Ted Cruz just creepy or our
salesmen you know the rest of them ben
Carson basically asleep so you know like
so is that really part of it that we
really are just looking for somebody to
just get that feeling from us and it's
like now I'll follow it survive
it is it's definitely a vibe it's all
unconscious 90% of communication you I
mean you know this right anybody has
ever dated you know if you're cross from
a woman well man you know whatever the
case is you know persons like this
looking at the phone
that's a vibe right every week and we go
based on vibes but we as human beings
want to believe that we're logical and
that we make conclusions based on what
we we look at the evidence and we have
all this information and stuff we don't
know we don't have all the information
the media lies about things the
government lies about things we have no
idea the Federal Reserve has never been
audited we have no idea about anything
mm-hmm and that's scary it's scary to
think that I'm just a regular schmuck
who knows nothing has no control but
that's where the guerrilla mindset comes
in I'm sort of like so people always
like oh yeah you're you're probably they
should probably out I'm like man if you
meet in you know we have met in real
life I'm pretty like mellow in real life
because I realized like I found that
[ __ ] control of [ __ ] like measure
here then you are Twitter I didn't know
what I was walking into tell ya I've a
little bit of control over how I feel
and what I think that's about it the
rest of the world is sort of out of my
control so we talked about this pre-show
you know your life is your life people
think Obama's gonna save them or ruin
them
people think that Sandra's is gonna save
him or ruin him people think that
Hillary's gonna ruin her life the same
with Trump why's Trump gonna ruin your
life or make your life and that isn't
even really a healthy way to go about it
so people view him as a savior though
but back to the original point is that
yeah he's got that vibe he's got that
swagger he's got correct watch him work
an audience right I always tell people
turn along and stand up half hey I said
this and Obama's a Muslim and Trump so I
didn't say he said it
oh I'll repeat what he said well don't
you dare say that I said Obama's a
Muslim I just or what the Ted Cruz is a
[ __ ] well I didn't say it but oh you
didn't hear what he said
no well that guy said Ted Cruz is a
[ __ ] but come on I would never say that
I'm running for president I mean that's
good [ __ ] so that's the that's the
interesting thing here because I want
people to say whatever they want and we
all know it's [ __ ] and they go it in
Congress and they said oh the gentleman
from buck and it's like we know you all
hate each other and you're all made
side deals and well that's so unmasking
that is all good and that's the part of
the Trump thing the train that I can get
on so maybe there will be some good the
other part I can't get there the part
about the policy stuff and what he
really believes and I get what you're
saying you're basically saying that
stuff doesn't matter cuz there's because
shits gonna go down either way I just
can't get there on that but I do
I accept your premise as to why other
people can get there Trump is
politically if I had to guess
politically centrist yeah I would put
him to the right of Obama but to the
left of everybody else running which is
why it all cracks me up that everybody
on the Left is scared shitless a trump
Trump is actually he's a rockefeller
liberal in New York liberal but he does
want to do something about immigration
he's raised the discussion that and I've
traveled to the Middle East I've met
Muslims there's more to it than America
knows we don't know the full story on
Muslims but we do know that Isis is
sending people in as refugees I know
that I want to Budapest Hungary and I
saw the refugees and look like you me
and people like this and way younger
there's 70 percent men and if you take
in 70 percent men you don't have enough
women right because they're mostly
heterosexual mm-hmm you now have gender
disbalance how are they gonna get laid
what's gonna happen are they gonna get
violent these are things that reasonable
people should be able to ask but if you
even ask that question you're done right
so you might as well just say [ __ ] it
[ __ ] it don't let don't let any of them
in and cuz people are gonna say you're
done anyway right so if I just said well
you know I was in I went to hungry I
went to the train stations I
investigated it for myself I did
reporting on it they're all men they're
all able-bodied they're all prime
fighting age why are they leaving the
women back home what what is really
going on well if you say that your
persona non-grata
anyway right so that's why you look even
if you look at the pictures coming out
where the migrants are crossing into
Greece and they're crossing into Germany
and whatever I was there like it's it's
all men it's all men in their 20s and
30s not a hundred percent but a huge
percentage of it and this is where I as
a liberal have been painted into a
corner here for the eight months that
I've been doing this show I've tried to
talk about the difference between ideas
and people and doctrine versus the
average
a person that may or may not be
religious and probably isn't oppressing
anyone and doesn't want to blow anything
up right but I've been left basically
with my 10 guys on the left and the
whole conversation has been handed to
trump so he's just taken the meet right
he's just taking the red meat on this
well because here's what I learned - and
that's why I'm kind of a little bit
while on Twitter as I realized that if
you if people ask me Mike what do you
really believe off the world I would say
well I think that generally speaking
women enjoy being more feminine and more
supportive for all of a man is more
dominant but if you want to be a woman
and you want to be a lawyer a CEO I
don't think anybody should stop you and
I think you should be careful not to
tell women what they have to do know
some pretty boring [ __ ] it's basic [ __ ]
right but if you put that online well
you your contribute to a culture of
internalized misogyny that your
hierarchy yeah yeah so you can't even
say that so you might as well say [ __ ]
it the best sex is rough sex and women
are crazy and they have wild sexual
fantasies and everything cuz they're
gonna come after you so you're doing the
Trump tactic yourself and you're
admitting it because basically you're
saying a pretty moderate guy if that
women can do whatever they want to do in
my view maybe they're better off at home
but they can do whatever they want to do
but when you're online you're staking
out this stuff because you just want to
keep rattling the cage because they're
gonna come after you anyway that's the
thing as feelings versus facts people
don't sit down and just have a rational
conversation oh people have written
about me before written about me tweets
nobody's ever said hey I read this tweet
where he told a guy to go kill himself
what did you really mean well the guy
told the kill himself
had actually tried to kill his
ex-girlfriend have was at a rehab and
burned a girl with cigarettes real bad
guy right and he was a troll who wasn't
really gonna kill himself he was doing
the whole I'm having a meltdown
therefore I'm mentally ill cuz that's
what you do when you do bad things now
right you go to rehab reclaim mental
illness but nobody says it what's the
context man what's the backstory so you
realize well you might as well be a
maniac you put on a good show the people
love it so when Trump I didn't know
about Trump that's the funny thing and
that's probably why I saw early on why
he was gonna do so Wallace I watched one
season The Apprentice when I was in law
school
right so I didn't really know anything
about Trump and I look what he didn't
like he's just doing what I do
but on a scale that is way bigger than I
do and what you're doing is you realize
that okay what do people love men women
drama people love drama
people love conflict conflict is
attention negative attention positive
because because you can take it hater
and turn that hater into a lover but you
can't turn people don't know buy you on
to anything yeah so you want to get
maximum attention yeah you know I don't
watch any reality shows I've maybe
watched them five minutes of Survivor
ever I never watched American Idol any
of that stuff the only reality show that
I've watched is the Celebrity Apprentice
so and this is you know five years ago
before he was running for president so
that I guess says it right there there
is something about him you're not gonna
convince me to vote it for him by the
end of this but that I can understand
the logic of it and I thought also that
you know having someone on this a trump
supporter would be interesting because
everyone's just screaming at each other
right so we should match the the media
would love us to be sitting here
screaming at each other that would that
would help the narrative right yeah it
would help the narrative you know I
would get a lot of interview requests I
used to say stop calling me they don't
email anymore
because they talked me like wait a
minute you know they want me to play a
pro wrestling character this is what the
media wants and and that's why I do a
little bit online because I realize like
okay I grew up watching 80s Pro
Wrestling I'm just the heel I'm the bad
guy
Brett might as well be Ric Flair the
Million Dollar Man you know I might as
well just because they're gonna make me
one anywhere as Mike Tyson said I could
speak to all eloquently but you're gonna
call me a [ __ ] rapist anyway so I
might as well right just be crazy I
think they're second Jake the snake
Roberts was my favorite rest he was a
good guy but didn't went back he didn't
have many friends on his side
so I feel like maybe that was the right
guy for me yeah exactly yeah but think
about it right think about Trump you how
hard is a media game right how hard is
well I guess if you're Trump it's not
that hard easy well that's that's that's
what I'm saying yeah so you have all
these people in the media you know you
have a personal brand I have a personal
brand but you'll see some guy you know
that have a job with the Washington Post
who say Trump doesn't know what he's
doing he's an idiot I'll go on the guy's
Twitter
and I'm like dude you write at the
Washington Post and you're like 1500
followers like I have 31 and it's all
organic following you know I sell more
books and these guys and everything
because I'm real I know who does what
because you can look at Amazon sales
ranks and I'm like you don't get it the
media game is hard Trump is winning it
so maybe instead of saying list guys
evil why don't you just take us that
back breathe and say well what is he
doing and then say well why is he doing
it so that's interesting because I've
noticed in the last few days since the
rally at Chicago that got canceled
that the media definitely I hate using
the phrase the media as it's this
monolith but the the mainstream media
and even a lot of the online stuff
they've really doubled down now on Trump
is evil and all that stuff now again I
started this show by giving a litany of
reasons why I'm not voting for this guy
but I think that every time BuzzFeed
puts out an article saying why he's evil
or every time Politico does it or
especially anything that's on the left
right so New York magazine or thing I
think they're just strengthening him and
they what I don't understand is do you
guys not understand psych 101
did none of you go to college because
all you're doing is making him stronger
okay so everybody most of them don't
understand it but some of them do but
ultimately we're all in the big media
matrix okay I'll uncover a media hoax
and then the next day I'll be like oh
yeah I wrote this article and whatever
that I just said yesterday is a piece of
[ __ ] you know now I'm saying well that's
an interesting story on this so we're
all kind of caught in the matrix and in
that regard the savvy people know that
they are ultimately building his brand
but they're getting clicks but they're
getting views as well we just all
deserve the [ __ ] that what do you
want at the end of the day right because
everything I know for a fact that if we
did this show a little bit differently
so you know in the YouTube game for
example if we titled things a little
differently we could double our clicks
like that and I've had many meetings
with my guys and I'm just like I'm not
gonna do it I just don't want to build
something in that way but plenty of
other people are so we all deserve the
the crap that was getting because we're
building the crab's yeah I tried to have
a debate with the guy once and we had a
real civil talk just like we're talking
now and then the YouTube thing went on
and he's just uh and I thought are we
gonna scream at each other but that's
what people
yeah you know that is that is what moves
so everybody screams at everybody
everybody online and she's saying well
you're an MRI evil em our men's rights
activists evil this your evil is we are
evil feminists you're an evil that that
yeah that's what people want but then it
becomes you know you as an artist you
have to to find your own integrity and
my integrity I think Trump's integrity
to us I ultimately have a very good
message I wrap it up in drama conflict
and all that other stuff but smart
people see through it right I can kind
of say okay you know I kind of see
what's going on I get you see through
the theatrics Trump is somebody he cares
a lot about America and he does what
nobody else running does okay we are
Americans we have the right to have an
identity as a nation we have the right
to have a culture we have the right to
say you as an American I care more about
you than I care about people in China
Bangladesh Romania Nigeria nobody else
is saying that and that's where
nationalism comes in and that's another
reason that he's doing well is it's this
idea that yeah I'm an American you don't
hear that much now a lot of people even
the the sort of chattering class the
so-called intellectuals would say well
nationalism is bad and you're part of a
global society you think you're part of
a global society but go travel somewhere
and you'll find right away that they
don't think you're part of a global
society so is that why his slogan even
make America great again
first off everyone wants things to be
great so that's okay but also throwing
the word again in there implies that we
lost something great we're gonna get
that thing back versus Bernie's which is
a future to believe in yeah so Bernie's
not talking about getting a feeling back
he's saying well something out there is
pretty good and Trump's going we lost
some [ __ ] so really it's just about
which part of the brain these guys are
taught on from PACs more information in
a slogan or a tweet than anybody else
does he jams and Lantos worth so yeah
make America great again if you're an
advertising you're marketing that's
aspirational you know that if you're in
marketing you want an app to be an
aspirational good Trump is an
aspirational this is all this is what
pisses me this is a [ __ ] marketing
yeah how can all these people who claim
they know marketing not just sit and say
okay Trump is running an ad camp
Trump is an aspirational good Trump is
saying make America great again
that's an aspirational slogan and it's
tying on nationalistic feelings like
America and make is a very sort of
can-do word and Americans have a can-do
attitude I mean the guy wrote a book
about yeah right he's doing what's in
his book right so this stuff used to
sort of you know that's where I have to
use the crow mindset it's like maddening
I'm like don't you aren't intelligent
people
you can't just analyze this but again
that's because that's my own weakness
I'm thinking the people are logical if
you're logical you would just sit down
and say okay here's what Trump does you
read its tweets many people have said
that I'm the greatest man in the world
well what has he done there well social
proof many people because we are monkeys
well if many people think it must be
true
he's not bragging because he's not
saying that that's what many people are
saying so a lot of times you could just
sit down and look at Trump's tweets read
them and really see them this guy used
this language well so they go is an
idiot he's a buffoon and I said no no no
you're the [ __ ] buffoon because I can
explain it just very logically
everything is the social proof he uses
cognitive biases you know in college you
learn the logical fallacies to make good
arguments well what if you're a Sophists
and you take the logical fallacies to
trick people to be a Sophos right maybe
you're not dumb maybe you're the smart
guy because the reason that you learn to
analyze logical fallacies is because we
are lazy thinkers and fallacies work
it's just a good way of manipulating
yeah so maybe you know people like oh
you're if you logic use a logical
fallacy you're stupid maybe but if
you're using a logical fallacy you get
people to draw false inferences marco
rubio's and a foam party well I've said
I haven't said anything but Marco Rubio
said that he was in a foam party well
I'm not using the fallacy of getting you
to draw a false inference right that it
must have been some gay thing and is he
really in the closet well I didn't say
that
Yeah right you you say you've said it
yeah yeah I mean I get it I fully go
you're saying it's such a dangerous
slippery slope and some people are gonna
play the game so I guess that's what it
is people are angry at him because he's
playing the game at a higher level